SPEAK TO OUR INITIAL SHUTDOWN
WAS TO PREVENT THE OVERFLOW OF
OUR HOSPITALS AND TO ALLOW US TO
MEET THE DEMANDS CAUSED BY THIS
GLOBAL PANDEMIC INCLUDING THE
VENTILATORS AND A PERMANENT
SHUTDOWN WAS REALLY NEVER AN
OPTION IN TERMS OF WHAT WE ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW.
THIS WOULD BE COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE, PRODUCE
DEBILITATING ECONOMIC FALL BACK
AND IT LEAD TO CATASTROPHIC
PUBLIC HEALTH CONSEQUENCES.
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES TO
SHUTDOWNS.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF COURSE AT HIS
CORONAVIRUS PRESS BRIEFING
TODAY.
FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT
MARC SIEGEL IS ON HIS WAY WAY TO
WASHINGTON TONIGHT, WE ARE
SENDING HIM TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO INTERVIEW THE PRESIDENT BUT
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
TO CONTAIN THE WORK ON
CORONAVIRUS AREAS HERE AT
8:00 P.M. EASTERN.
AND PART NUMBER TWO IS ON
SHANNON SHOW AT 11.
BUT FIRST A NEW RUN DOWN, ED
SMITH, THE OWNER OF PATEL AS GYM
IN BELMAR, NEW JERSEY, WE SPOKE
TO HIM EARLIER THIS YEAR AND HE
TRIED TO OPEN HIS GYM IN
DEFIANCE OF THE STATE SHUTDOWN
ORDER AND NOW HE’S TAKING
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES TO STAY
OPEN.
EVEN REMOVED HIS FRONT DOOR TO
PREVENT THE STATE FROM KEEPING
THE DOOR CLOSED.
TOO BAD HE IS NOT AN ABORTION
CLINIC OR LIQUOR STORE, HE WOULD
HAVE NO PROBLEM AT ALL.
SO THE STATE IS TRYING TO SHUT
YOU DOWN.
IS THERE -- FIRST TO THE
SCIENCE.
IS THERE EVIDENCE THAT YOUR GEM
HAS BEEN A VECTOR FOR A HOTBED
OF THE SPREAD OF CORONAVIRUS?
>> WE HAVE RECORD OF EVERY
SINGLE PERSON WHO HAS STEPPED
FOOT AND OF THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
CHECK INS WELL INTO THE
THOUSANDS.
NOT A SINGLE CASE HAS BEEN
REPORTED SO FAR AND WITH KEPT
DETAILED RECORDS OF THAT ALL THE
WAY THROUGH.
>> Tucker: IT’S HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN BETTER OFF JOINING A MOB OF
RIOTERS, WHY ARE YOU BEING
HOUNDED BY THE STATE DO YOU
THINK?
>> I THINK WE ARE BEING HOUNDED
BY THE STATE BECAUSE WE ARE
PUSHING BACK AGAINST A VERY,
VERY CLEAR POLITICAL AGENDA AT
THIS POINT AND WE HAVE BECOME A
THORN IN THE SIDE FOR
GOVERNOR MURPHY.
MY PARTNER AND I ARE NOT WILLING
TO BACK DOWN AND WE ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE OUR LIVES
DESTROYED OVER A POLITICAL
AGENDA THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH US?
>> SO WHAT IS THE GOVERNOR
THREATENING TO DO TO YOUR GEM?
>> OF POLICE FORCE WAS
THREATENING US WITH CITATION
AFTER CITATION, THEN AS THE
COURT SYSTEM, THE COURT SYSTEM
ENFORCE THE SHUTDOWN AND LOCK
OUR DOORS ON US AND WE FINALLY
GOT THEM REMOVED.
WEWE HAD WORKOUTS OUTSIDE FOR A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND IT WAS
ABSURD.
WE WERE DRAGGING HALF OF THE GYM
OUTSIDE, CLOSE TO 30,000 POUNDS
OF EQUIPMENT EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND ON JULY 4TH WE RESUMED
ANOTHER COURT IS BEING
WEAPONIZED AGAINST US.
WE WERE HELD IN CONTEMPT OF
COURT AND WE NARROWLY ESCAPED
THAT LAST NIGHT.
AGAIN, IT’S JUST A WEAPONIZATION
OF THESE PUBLIC ORGANIZATIONS
AND OFFICES THAT ARE MEANT TO
SERVE AND PROTECT THE PEOPLE AND
THEY ARE CLEARLY BEING USED TO
PUNISH US.
>> Tucker: AND A CERTAIN KIND
OF PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE AN ABORTION CLINIC,
HE WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM.
DO YOU THINK IT’S ODD THAT THEY
ARE PERSECUTING YOU?
>> I THINK IT POINTS TO THE VERY
CLEAR FACT THAT THIS IS NOT
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH.
FIRST OF ALL, PUBLIC HEALTH IS
NOT A ONE-DIMENSIONAL ISSUE, IT
DOES NOT START AND FINISH WITH
COVID.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS WE HAVE
TO CONSIDER, MENTAL HEALTH BEING
ONE OF THEM.
EVERYTHING THAT SEEMS TO BE
UNHEALTHY FOR YOU, OR AT LEAST
SORT OF AVERAGE IS ALLOWED, BUT
YOU CAN’T GO WORK OUT.
THE STUDIES ALL AROUND THE WORLD
COMING OUT OF NORWAY, WHILE THE
SCIENCE POINTS TO THE FACT THAT
IF YOU ALLOW PEOPLE TO WORK OUT
REGULARLY, THEY PROVIDED NO DATA
TO SHOW THAT GYMS ARE OF NO
DANGER TO ANYBODY.
AND THEY COLLECTED A BUNCH OF
STUDIES AND THEY ALL HAD THIS
INFORMATION.
IT’S ALMOST LIKE THEY ARE TRYING